That 70s Show followed the exploits of a
lovable band of Misfits just trying to
get by in Point Place Wisconsin the de
facto leader of the group was Eric
Forman who had a relatively consistent
relationship with a girl named Donna
together with their friends Jackie Kelso
Fez and Hyde they got into all sorts of
shenanigans often earning the ire of
Eric's father red and the sympathy of
his mother Kitty in January 2023 a
sequel series that 90s show landed on
Netflix picking up 15 years after the
end of the original series this time
around red and kitty are the main
returning characters who look after a
new crop of kids including Eric and
Donna's daughter Leia this is my life
and I'm done letting it suck Leia yeah
go just unload baby both barrels
naturally some familiar faces outside of
red and kitty make an appearance but
there's one notable absence from the
proceedings Danny Masterson's hide isn't
anywhere to be found and no one even
mentions him in the first season so what
happened hide isn't anywhere to be found
but the rest of his Old Point Place
buddies show up in that 90s show in the
first episode Eric and Donna are back in
town with their daughter to attend Red's
4th of July celebration while their
intention was to merely stay the weekend
Leia convinces her parents to let her
spend the summer with her grandparents
through this Leia meets a new friend Jay
who's the son of Kelso and Jackie who
also make an appearance in the pilot
everyone's return to the spin-off series
makes sense and is in line with their
characters even though Kelso and Jackie
weren't together when That 70s Show
ended they reunited and in fact they're
looking to get remarried so where does
that leave Hyde none of the cast members
or Netflix have officially commented on
Danny Masterson's absence but it makes
sense why he isn't there if you've
stayed up to date with his personal life
in 2020 Masterson was charged with
raping three women during separate
incidents between 2001 and 2003. however
allegations of such Behavior date back
to 2017 when Masterson was a cast member
on the Netflix series The Ranch when the
accusations first surfaced Netflix
quickly wrote Masterson out of the
series and released a statement after
discussing with producers we've decided
to write any Masterson off of the wrench
yesterday was his last day of work and
we'll make new episodes in 2018 without
him Masterson denied the allegations but
it went forward with a trial in January
2021 Masterson pleaded not guilty and in
December 2022 a mistrial was declared
the jury was split on all three charges
of sexual assault but the women at the
center of the case insist the fight is
far from over after the mistrial two of
the Jane does released a statement we
are obviously disappointed that at least
for the time being Daniel Masterson has
evaded criminal accountability for his
deplorable acts however we are
collectively resolved to continue our
fight for justice including in Civil
Court as such it makes sense that 90s
show would want to distance itself from
Masterson and not even bring up Hyde if
you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault help is available
visit the rape abuse and incest National
Network website or contact rand's
National helpline at
1-800-656-hope that's 1-800-656
4673